We've been following breaking news
out of Tanzania
this morning
where several people have been rescued
after a commercial plane
with a number of passengers on board
crashed into Lake Victoria.
Yes, really remarkable pictures
that we're seeing.
You can see passengers
standing on the wings of the plane
as rescue boats ferry them back to shore.
A spokesperson
for Precision Air,
which owns
the aircraft, says a plane went down
near an airport
located on Lake Victoria's western shore.
And in a tweet, Tanzania's
president sent his condolences
to those affected
and urged calm
while rescuers continue
to search for survivors.
Let's talk more about this
now with Mary Schiavo.
She is a former inspector
general for the U.S.
Department of Transportation
and a CNN transportation analyst.
Hi there, Mary.
So just looking at the pictures,
what do you assess, at least in terms
of how the pilot reacted
and what may have happened?
Well, yes,
they were taking
off and taking off all over water.
I mean, there are.
That's the most dangerous
part of the flight, of course.
And this plane an ATR,
they used to fly in the United States,
but they really don't anymore.
There were a couple of crashes
and especially crashes and icing that
really saw them pass out of service
from the U.S..
But the remarkable thing is,
as as you reported,
that people were standing on the wings
because planes
you know, don't make very good boats.
And often
they think everyone remembers
the miracle on the Hudson
where the plane people
were standing on the wings
on the miracle on the Hudson.
But what people didn't realize is
a lot of boats came quickly
and they got lines on
the aircraft, pulled the lines
taut to keep it from sinking.
So the fact that they were able to get
the pilot was able to get the plane down
without crashing into the water,
but looks rather
like landing in the water
is is really pretty good
without knowing much more than that
at this point.
So the fact that 26
already have been rescued
out of 43 passengers on board,
that's very good for a crash or landing,
if you want to call it that, a
water landing
Yeah, we're just getting that information
now from the airline
and the Tanzanian authorities.
It appears as though
they are still in communication.
They were able to communicate
with the pilots in the cockpit
even when the plane was submerged.
Can you walk us through the process
of this kind of a rescue or
an emergency landing
as the plane is going down?
Where are the flight attendants
supposed to be doing?
Well, flight attendants,
because water's involved
there, couple things.
First of all,
they have to get them ready
for a brace landing, for a crash landing,
if you will.
And then they also have to get people
into now on a plane of this
size,
depending on
whether it usually operated over water.
It may not have life vests,
but they may have to use for
flotation is their seat cushion.
But if they regularly fly over water,
then they would have had life.
This would have been required
depending upon the rules of the nation.
So the flight attendants
would have had to been
getting them in their lives.
This if they had them,
but instructing them,
do not do not
do not open them in the cabin.
You can't
you have to wait until you get out
because otherwise you could
get trapped in the cabin.
So they have double emergency duty
to do
when it's suspected
that they're going to land on water.
But since you're standing on the wing
and that appears they were able
to get those messages across
and get them out.
Now, the problem also comes in,
some of the plane is submerged,
of course.
And so getting people out once they're
underwater is very difficult.
You know, lighting becomes an issue
that's a real problem.
And so they literally would have to help
and help
lead people, get people out of the plane,
which has happened
in other water landings.
The flight attendants
you know, rescue rescue lifeguards.
Yeah, it's a total of 43 people on board.
And so far, 26
and more than half have been rescued
that is good news.
Just want to ask you about this.
I found this interesting.
A local official
was quoted as saying
that they are trying to check
if the wheels of the plane hit the ground
under water.
And just judging from the pictures,
you can see the water is pretty shallow.
People are standing up
to some people's knees and waist.
Is there a chance?
Does it look like to you
that the wheels did
hit the ground out of that lake?
Yes.
That would explain why
it didn't sink,
because planes sink very, very quickly.
And that would explain also
why if the plane is resting on the ground
and that
people are still able to get out,
why there's why
there is at this point,
without knowing more
there's a very good chance
that perhaps everybody
could have survived
so miraculous
that the wheels will touch the ground.
Otherwise the plane would sink
very quickly, extremely quickly.
In fact,
You know,
and when I went to flight school,
the instruction was
if you're landed on water
and you're,
you know,
get your passengers
and you out, don't for any reason
if the plane even if it hasn't sunk
yet, do not go back to that aircraft
because it will sink quickly.